jacques attali vous y croyez vous voyez
vous met d'ailleurs avec l'arrivée des
trucs de ouf et moi c'était c'était en
bretagne et on voulait faire une séance
de spiritisme avec un guéridon et moi
j'y croyais pas du tout à ça ne va pas
du tout il y avait ma mère tu verras il
faudra qu'on était en face de l'île de
sein et mon grand-oncle s'est noyé à
lille de sarov syrie et donc on a
commencé à faire une séance de
spiritisme esprit es tu là et tout d'un
coup je vous jure que c'est vrai j'ai
regardé deux sociétés le guéridon s'est
soulevée plus jeunes et à traverser la
pièce et a descendu trois marches
d'escalier non 3 c'est tout écouter mais
il ya beaucoup pour gagner donc c'est
pas très sportif
terrorisée on aimerait arrêter tout de
suite la séance
on est parti se coucher et ne courra pas
sauter c'était une horreur dans mes
cheveux réjouir c'est vrai quand vous
êtes allez vous coucher quand même
abattu je fasse je pas rester dans la
pièce ville fantôme
mais se déplacera manager dans la pièce
moi j'ai regardé deux solitaires y avait
plus aucune main sur lui ride on était à
sa au dessus du sol il vous dirait
l'autre volet vous êtes sûr vous saviez
les mêmes violée pendant benzema mais il
y avait la grand mère mais je vous jure
c'est vrai j'ai appelé ma mère je n'y
croyais pas du tout ces poubelles avant
oui tout à fait en plus c'est très
dangereux de faire du spiritisme et tout
ce qu'on voit là comme 8 jacques
anquetil et eux qui sont sorties pour
les enfants d'ailleurs ces derniers
temps parce que quand on fait du
spiritisme qu'on invoque on appelle ddd
voilà des énergies généralement qu'est
ce qui arrive c'est toutes ces entités
c'est à dire celle des personnes qui
sont dans des plans intermédiaire quand
on meurt en fait
soit on passe dans un autre plan de
conscience plus lumineux sont reste
entre les deux plans parce qu'on n'a pas
réglé certaines choses en notre matière
notamment en matière ces personnes là on
entre deux blocs au fait c'est ça les
gens qui sont venus d'horizons et
renforçant et donc pour de
l'espace-temps donc osé infinie ah oui
oui vous vous n'y croyez pas non j'ai
combattu tout mais j'entends qu'à ce
stade je connais très bien et trois
marchés pas plus tôt trois verres
[Rires]
alors gouverneur montiel vous y croyez
ce qui vous est arrivé un truc de ouf
aussi et c'est pourquoi même plusieurs
je vais essayer d'être court on avait
loué mais pas du tout mais pas du tout à
château effrayant un château normale et
c est un habitué des t4 pour lui cette
baisse château chacun habiter dans une
aile du château est alors moi j'ai vu
quelqu'un rentre et rentrer et sortir
fait les activités et c'est aberrant
évidemment j'ai eu peur car en 13 ans
tient qu'à rentrer dans ma le gardien du
ch alors la chambre n'ont pas du tout
quelqu'un en train de la chambre si vous
voulez je les décris lendemain à mes
amis qui m'ont dit bon ils sont foutus
de ma gueule etc
sauf qu'un jour on reçoit la
propriétaire du château mais j'avais
parfaitement décrit le mec que je voyais
un équipe qui regardaient la place était
bizarre mais c'est quoi le gars il fait
et rien il rentrait pas il allait à la
fenêtre et rester des heures à regarder
la fenêtre attend des rentrées leurs
pièces et regardez là c'est mon désir
c'est julien courbet connaît donc quoi
le gars il rentre alors dans des mets
toi tu vois un gars je t'embrouille pas
avec lui si je lui parle à rdi la
regarder tranquillement alors me dit pas
si les jeux sur pas je ne sais pas je
les ai vus bien passé il sait qu'il a
des chaussures ou pas faire il avait
quoi ils avaient des sarenza.com rien je
sais même plus ce qu'il avait et il
arrivait mais il est venu fréquemment
donc si vous voulez je vais parfaitement
décrire et comme dans votre chambre que
dans votre chambre et je vais
parfaitement décrire mes amis de la
chaleur il a regardé les bronzés tâche
donc bon terminé je décris parfaitement
le bonhomme que je voyais à mes amis qui
évidemment son fils michael sauf qu'un
jour on a reçu la propriétaire du
château et qui nous a raconté que son
fils était mort moi j'aime absolument
pas fait le rapprochement je n'étais pas
au courant et elle nous sort une photo
de son fils c'était le gars vous avez
parfaitement décrit s'était lui désolé
et cfa 10 mai lire tous les jours
moins de bruit j'ai souvent vu des
choses mais voilà si on voit pas dans
les annales
dans les grès portugal alors qu'on a une
vidéo incroyable c'est celle d'élise à
l'âme
c'est une jeune femme qui a
mystérieusement disparu elle a été
filmée pour la dernière fois dans
l'ascenseur d'un hôtel avec un
comportement très étrange ça aussi ça
n'a jamais été expliqués vous connaissez
cette histoire 1,10 à l'âme
non c'est bas s'élève à garder ses les
vraies images sur les images vidéo de
l'hôtel la jeune femme entre dans
l'ascenseur elle semble seul du moins en
apparence
sur les images on voit elisa qui semble
se cacher de quelqu'un il faut aussi se
demander qu'est ce qu'elle fait dans cet
ascenseur au 14e étage alors que sa
chambre et en cinquième
et puis tout à coup elle sort
brusquement de la cabine hélas son
comportement devient très étrange elle
va avoir des gestes complètement
hallucinant comme s'il était poursuivi
par ou suivis par une présence invisible
et puis revendre brusquement dans la
cabine
elle ressort une dernière fois et là on
perd sa trace après oui alors et donc
alors ça vous connaissez cette histoire
ou quoi ah non je connaissais pas cette
histoire est une histoire ou fauci alors
vous vous n'y croyez vous êtes assez
canal c est moi je suis un peu comme
vous c'est à dire qu'elle m'est jamais
arrivé donc comme ça n'est jamais arrivé
je n'y crois pas en revanche je
comprends que ça puisse impressionné
qu'on puisse fantasmer qu'on puisse être
fasciné par ça mais je pense que je suis
trop rationnel et je me dis qu'en fait
il ya forcément une explication est que
la science par exemple n'a pas encore
tout expliquer alors une raison
peut-être que tu as vu sans le savoir
dans son inconscient
une peinture c'est ça me plait tôt et
finalement tu il a imprimé un peu plus
loin dans ton cerveau et voilà ta
fantasmer nous tapons que c'est ce qu'un
traité je suis sincèrement nous les
aurons alors oui annabelle mais il ya
quand même
aujourd'hui on a quand même la capacité
de prendre des photos avec des
infrarouges et on arrive à visualiser
justement des entités des formes la
reconnaître des visages etc dans des
essais dans des lieux justement alors la
jeune femme l'a donc retrouvé trois
semaines après morte dans la cuve de
l'hôtel non pas dans le réservoir à eau
du poteau alors qu'il ya aucune façon
d'aller là bas donc c'est vrai que c'est
assez curieux voilà le jeu je vais mener
l enquête prochainement mais l'a pour
l'instant elle n'est pas les tonneaux et
les vous il vous est déjà arrivé quelque
chose dont je me suis fait visiter en
pleine nuit
[Rires]
c'était agréable d'il ya trois ans
j'étais en provence je mes parents et je
dors très beau monde à menville environ
3 heures du matin et là je sens qu'on me
prend on me prend
on me prenait d'accord me soulever de
quelques centimètres et j'ai ressenti au
au fond de moi une sorte de lumière
blanche un peu aveuglante extrêmement
puissante
j'avais le coeur qui battait la chamade
c'était tellement puissant que j'ai
demandé à cette entité je ne sais pas
quoi cette énergie de me reposer je me
suis reposé les gens voulaient très
simplement veux-tu me reposer veux-tu me
reposer alors on est au chocolat quoi
vous tu me reposer crise les déficits
est presque crispée je ne pouvais même
pu maîtriser ce ne pouvait pas ouvrir
les yeux c'était rêver non
il m'a posé par ya deux choses me
reposer je me suis réveillé j'étais
transpirant comme jamais je ne trahis et
le truc bizarre c'est que je venais de
terminer un livre sur les anges gardiens
alors y at il un lien afin de passage
alors je vous dis là ne vais pas arriver
la même chose qui est arrivée à un mec
que je connais pas ce que j'ai entendu
en balance ton post exactement c'est
cédric llopez il raconté sétif a enlevé
par des extra-terrestres et il vous est
arrivé exactement pratiquement la même
chose
est-ce que vous avez le souvenir d'un
coude d'un connard pas regarder parce
que regarder
non je suis comme ça voilà une porte qui
saurait prix il y en a un plus grand
cette performance est comme une mante
religieuse aie aie aie avec un truc
quand toi quoi il montre lien ouais
est-ce qui vous a donné qu'elle arrive
là le sasso et blanc et on me met dans
les fesses il vous met quelque chose
dans les fesses ouais c'était quoi bein
il y avait un truc comme c'était
c'était comme un inconnu
je compose j'ai l'impression d'être
d'essentiel la même histoire sans le co
reste le côté c'est possible ça ce qu'on
entend là ou pas annabelle oui c'est
possible mais là moi pour moi on n'a
plus affaire encore à un esprit est
quelque chose qui est peut-être pas
d'ordre extraterrestre aujourd'hui on va
quand même aussi de cette union des
tractations commencent à dire que tout
ce que vous entendez là ça vous semble
pas un koala mais pas du tout c'est ce
que mais parce que nous sommes des de la
matière la matière c'est l'énergie
content c'est quand on meurt une autre
champ énergétique notre champagne juste
ses parts dans notre corps physique une
petite corde d'argent qui retient les
deux j'ai l'âme et l'esprit s'en va et
cette mémoire que nous avons été reste
et quand une personne justement la danse
dans cette histoire de château ça c'est
la mémoire de ce garçon fait et le mec
regarder vidéo gag lui n'est pas parti
lui n'est pas parti parce qu'en fait ils
devaient peut-être est très accroché à
son lieu où est quelque chose qui a été
mal vécue au moment de son départ
d'oncle apparemment il n'est pas parti
là on est peut-être soutien n'est pas
avoir sa mère à ce monde du vélo ce
qu'il est mais l'autre est le gage
d'adorer farouk ou même le chien près
après ça dépend de la france ça veut
dire que peut-être que vous avez une
sensibilité peut-être spéciale sur moi
que vous qu'appeler les choses parce que
souvent ces êtres là vont se manifester
j'ai des personnes qui ont cette
sensibilité cette capacité de pouvoir
les accueillir et de recevoir et voir
qu'est-ce qu'un radar ne vous le dira
pas mais il est un peu médium danse pas
vrai alors qui va être viré l'année
prochaine je veux blesser personne mais
un art est immédiat un peu tu as vu des
trucs qu'il est souvent je vais vous
dire la vérité ce que tu as vu n'ont
alors pas ici du tout ici c'est
tellement bizarre ces années vous avez
eu du chocolat
[Rires]